[Music]
ah
[Applause]
um
i i honestly never thought a decade ago
i'd ever get to say this again but [ __ ]
this is gonna be fun ladies and
gentlemen welcome to smod castle
as you all know well by now but if you
don't just to fill in the
folks that come in late we are literally
feet away from the cradle of
civilization quick stop
if you all were smart you got your
drinks and your refreshments and quick
stop that was part of the dream of this
place and the dream of this place began
the week we went on tour with jay and
salam bob
reboot it was when we came out to do the
asbury park show
at the paramount and me and
ernie and rajiv started having this
conversation about like well what would
happen if we
took the end space and it was just a
conversation
so when i got on stage at the paramount
naturally i was like we're opening the
[ __ ] smart castle
because that's how i operate like a lot
of times in order to make things a
reality you gotta throw your hat
over the wall so to speak you gotta will
that [ __ ]
into existence but all the will in the
world ladies and gentlemen uh
of one lone person means absolutely
[ __ ] nothing
unless you've got support you're
standing uh in
in a reality of a dream i was just a guy
that was like wouldn't it be [ __ ]
great
if like we came back to the place where
it all started and [ __ ] like there's got
to be powerful
ley lines under the earth right under
quick stop if we have a [ __ ] theater
what could come from last time we had a
theater
hollywood babylon was born jane salan
bob get old was born and stuff
who knows what could come from it again
it dies
right there if it's me left to my own
devices because i'd be like yeah that'd
be cool
and then i go on with everything else
but mercifully
mercifully yes mercifully um i am
surrounded by
uh people that can make a difference and
stuff and i've known
somebody since i was a kid who i used to
make pretend with and [ __ ] play with
and dream with and
this doesn't exist without him
otherwise it's just me going like we
should do that one day
and then one day i drop dead and it
never gets done but the man who
literally built the [ __ ] place that
you're standing the castle keeper
himself
deserves all the [ __ ] credit he was
doing this [ __ ] during covid
um when he was don't tell the talent
when he wasn't supposed to be doing it
um and then like when he was done here
he went and [ __ ] rebuilt
jay and silent bob's secret stash so he
has had a busy busy [ __ ] year
um and he he built the place that we're
standing in tonight
god willing this gets to be ernie's
retirement
you don't have to be a [ __ ] builder
anymore and throw his back out
he gets to just run [ __ ] smog castle
if it always looks like this
he's gonna have a [ __ ] bright future
give it up for one of my best friends in
the world kids one of the first people i
ever dreamed with and this is [ __ ]
important
it's a very important thing the most
important thing stranger will ever tell
you in your lives
the day you find somebody who's willing
to dream your dreams for you you hold on
to them with
everything you [ __ ] got those people
are rare rare
gems let me show you one of the rarest
gems in the world welcome to the stage
castle keeper
ernest o'donnell ladies and gentlemen
i love this man i love him
i want i want to publicly uh i got to
thank the man
uh he's never forgotten
pretty much with me where he's come from
he always said we'd do something
together
and to do it locally here in our
i mean a stone's throw away from our
hometown and where
clerks originated in 1994
uh i thought at first i thought it was
nuts
i was like you want to do what you're
going to retire me he goes well i'll
retire you after you build me the smart
castle
but first you're going to build me the
stash and so i was like
i might get a broken back from both but
i
i really appreciate you all coming out i
mean this is this is great
i mean uh it's been a long ride for me
and kev
i mean i've been there since the
beginning it's almost 45 years now i
think
we met when we were uh well i was we i
in fifth grade so wait
that's great yeah so i was 10.
ernie we can talk about this now yeah
it was painful then but like ernie got
left ernie got left back i got left back
that's how we we met but when you're a
kid you never say that because that's
like [ __ ] like you know the dreaded
like the scarlet letter and [ __ ]
but as adults like without you getting
left back we never hang out
you're just some tough older boy i'm
like i'm scared of that ernie o'donnell
kid and [ __ ] yeah
but because ernie got left back we met
and i was 10 and ernie ernie was always
a little older so ernie got a license
before me
so i got to learn how to drive on
ernie's truck my father was like i guess
i should teach you to drive i was like
ernie did it that's right all done
my father was like oh he's gonna [ __ ]
your mother too or what
it's like if he's got a man grace was
scared this grace scared the [ __ ] out of
me i
listen i love that woman like another
mother but
there's no way i would ever do anything
bad about her but i mean are you saying
when you [ __ ] it's bad
no well i would never cry with sex well
you let's
let's get it clear you used to look up
to me too because i was the first one
that was bowling before you
that's true yes yeah the world we were
revealing old secrets and [ __ ]
ernie did he was bowling we'd have those
comments we'd have those conversations
on the phone hey aaron how was it man
what's it like what do you do what are
you
bernie was the astronaut the one that
was just like i felt a
we're like boob how could that happen
you're catholic
um and here we are today playing playing
like we did like kids
we would go play raiders of lost ark and
[ __ ] i'd be bellock and he would be
[ __ ] indie jones and [ __ ]
we're gonna do that again i guarantee
you we're going to do a reading of
raiders of the lawsuit
oh i'd love it and you get to be in new
york kevin's famous line when we were
recording on what was on the beta what
was the beta we used
um no super 8 super 8 right
the only line i really remember is kevin
on a mountaintop
we had this well it wasn't really a
mountaintop tell us it was a mountaintop
he was just like
playing a play his famous line the whole
thing was
jones that's it that was my life
the guy that wrote clerks that was his
line jones
he'd be like i'd be like i'll give you
one last chance and he's like i have a
bazooka
um hopefully our games will be better
than that yes um but yeah man we dreamed
as kids and [ __ ] and like oh wouldn't it
be great to do this [ __ ] and
we had a mayor of our hometown oh yeah
bob wilson who was like
actually in the movie business he was a
prop master
uh in flint uh tootsie was the big one
right tootsie was the huge one which
like the whole it rocked the towns well
because it became like 100 million
dollar movie
and the whole town was like our mayor is
in [ __ ] tootsie
and not even like you know just walking
past at one point he does walk past
dustin off in the hallway and he goes
hey bob
but he's got a very famous shot in the
movie the camera
takes off his wig he's standing by the
camera and he's the one that just passes
out and [ __ ]
yeah that was our mayor and we looked up
to him not politically because he was
republican
but we definitely looked up to him
because he was in [ __ ] tootsie
and his wife had a thrift store miss
brooks
trunk so it's tiny ass thrift store way
[ __ ] way smaller than this like a
quarter of this place
the size of the stage probably jammed
with like [ __ ]
antiques but we assumed that since they
were married
he would bring props home and that she
would try to sell them sooner or later
so every day after school we would go to
mrs wig's trunk where this older woman
was trying to sell like
antique tchotchkes and we were like you
got any of that dustin hoffman [ __ ]
[Laughter]
we actually though we did get we did get
a prop
from mr wilson what'd you get i got a uh
a newspaper
from uh oh guys i never told kevin that
this is like that different strokes
episode where you're like or something
um wow man you got an actual [ __ ] yes
and i got a button
some sort of button from some movie i
had no clue what it was but you know why
you got a prop and i didn't
your mom worked for the bird ah yes my
mom was a court clerk for about 40
40 years that's just political yes sorry
everything's about politics um
kids we're not alone we don't get to do
this uh without another partner
and uh that partner goes way back
uh to my very humble beginnings at the
very
end of this building when we were
sitting around talking like before we
did the
big premiere and whatnot of uh jay and
salam bob reboot
we started having this conversation
about like opening the space here and
whatnot and we were gonna just like all
right we'll
rent the space and renovate it and
[ __ ] run the place
but then uh rajiv was like well i want
it
because he's like look i'm old like you
i want to play
he said that rush i didn't and i was
like oh my god
[ __ ] yes like look at this look at
this look at this amateurish
[ __ ] right here
you had your phone on that's me castle
keeper [ __ ] [ __ ]
um i said uh come [ __ ] play with us
man like that's what this space is all
about and [ __ ] like just having a good
time and figuring things out and who
knows
what could come of it and whatnot so if
at the beginning of covid like you know
if we had
signed on just as two renters we would
have paid rent for a [ __ ] year
and nothing as as you knew was open and
[ __ ]
and we would have the business would
have died before we opened the [ __ ]
doors
like we would have been like it's
opening and then it's like it's closing
you missed it
mercifully um our partner owns the
building
and so was like i'll take the ride with
you guys so
rooms like this [ __ ] make that ride
worth it and he's been with us since the
beginning he was
raj was the guy who um
was in charge of ordering all the movies
in town
so you know every every [ __ ] time i
always found this fascinating because
i'm like
you set the [ __ ] tone for leonardo
man like
people only get to see what you want
them to [ __ ] see
so why did you buy six copies of richard
dreyfuss's let it ride
like [ __ ] like that blow my mind what's
the science here and also he would get
the
adult movies and shows which were in the
big boxes the pink door
door he would yes the pink door behind
the big door in the rst room
so he went up to the city to get those
so i was like you know i would tell
people i was like my boss is in the
he goes entertainment the city to get
the [ __ ] movies and [ __ ] so
um i've known him since i was a kid
since i started working here
then he went off and had a life and god
bless you and had family i was there at
his wedding and stuff
years later we reconnect over the
[ __ ] spot castle thing
and people find their place in your life
when it's time
when you need the most and and generally
speaking when they need you most as well
that's when it's very mutually
beneficial so like hanging out with him
for like the last year
um has made me feel like i did when i
was
in my 20s i'm just not afraid of getting
fired anymore like that's the big
[ __ ] difference
please welcome to the stage uh our
partner without whom there is no [ __ ]
smile castle without whom there's no
quick stop groceries ladies and
gentlemen give it up for rajiv topper
thank you it's gonna be an absolute
pleasure
to see all you guys here on the first
day it's awesome
i mean eye-opening experience for me but
you want to introduce them i think those
that's the key
i do we got a special treat for your
kids this is real uh
emotional for all of us um we don't get
to do this
you gotta sometimes you know as a stoner
you trace everything you try to trace
everything back to the origin point
and some things are impossible to trace
back so sometimes i'm like how did how
did this all happen and [ __ ] and where
how did clerks happen
i can trace it back to a certain point
where i'm involved
like ah without me it doesn't happen to
[ __ ] but when you can trace your story
even
further back to like oh my god if
choices aren't made by absolute
strangers
i don't get to do uh any of this years
ago
there was a man he lived in india um
he came over here his family put some
money together
came over here uh one as soon as he got
here didn't know where he was gonna work
a couple days after he got here the new
york times i guess the wan ads
had an article where they were like you
know looking for a yogi because what
year is this 1916
71 71 so like we're looking for a yogi
so mr topper the man that hired me
walks in and the guy goes oh you're
[ __ ] hired
[Laughter]
and he's like oh really yeah yeah he
looked apart and [ __ ] so instantly
he becomes a yogi like you know and
that's like the dream you come to
america and you find a [ __ ] job he
found a career
just like that that career led to like
him being able to bring
his wife over bring have kids here uh
bring his whole family have multiple
[ __ ] businesses
and then one day go like there's a
cumberland farms
you know in leonardo that's
closing where's the video first first it
was that one it is time watch the video
first
so it starts with a video store yeah so
we had a video store in staten island
branched out on our own came down to
leonardo stayed here and the store next
to us closed down
once that closed down that became quick
stuff that was so it was a cumberland
farm it was a cumberland so you guys
originally had the video store and the
anchor store was
cumberland farms so when cumberland
farms were shutting down we were going
to be in trouble
that was it we were going to be in
trouble so the only reason you buy quick
stop
is because you're like [ __ ] we need
people to buy milk in order to sell
videos you knew nothing about the
grocery store
um because of that decision and i guess
you know decision as we heard made out
of necessity without the store
it's like [ __ ] who's going to come buy
milk if they're not milk is going to
rent videos and stuff
a decision is made they enter the
convenience store
business what year is this this is 87 89
89 89.
so in 1990
that's when i see an ad um in the
uh i guess it was the press or the
courier probably
in the wan ads about video store clerk
and i was like oh my god what a dream
job that would be [ __ ] watch movies
for a living that's a [ __ ] incredible
even better than making movies watching
movies for a living
so i came to interview uh for the dream
job
and the play you know when i came in
the video store was closed there was a
sign said go to the convenience store
so i went next door to the convenience
or something i would live for the next
five years of my life and [ __ ] ever
hanging that sign and going next door
so i went next door because i'm here to
interview
and i met miss chopper he goes oh come
with me and he brought me next to her
and you know those little like
footstools like you know they sell at
[ __ ] target and [ __ ] like just
they're tiny like if this is the floor
they go up this high and [ __ ]
so it's literally just a one step thing
he had two of those to go sit
[Laughter]
and so we crouched on the floor sat down
and you know he's been doing yoga his
whole life so he's limber as [ __ ] and
whatnot
so he could drop right in the lotus
position i was like can i get some help
here i was 20 something
so we sit on these two tiny ass little
stools and we're behind the counter so
if this is the counter
of rst video this is what you would have
seen
people like what kind of video store is
this
so um he was looking at the resume i
filled out and whatnot and
he goes you like movies and i said yeah
and i remember he was just like well
that's a drawback
because he knew then that i'd be like
i'm gonna watch and get the newest
movies and stuff like that
so he said um do you you know how to
like work at a convenience store i see
here you've worked at convenience stores
and i'd worked at a bunch of stuff so i
was like yeah i said i don't
i don't really want to do that you know
i i want to work in a video store i
dream about working on a video tour
but you know i can do convenience store
work and he goes well if i hire you for
the video store would you mind
from time to time coming over to work
at quickstop and i was like you know if
you ever need me
like in a rush you know when i'm not
putting videos on the shelves like
yeah i could totally come over and help
you out
and so uh he hired me right at that
point and stuff
and what i found out was it was really a
convenience store job
with some side work in the video store
it was a bait and switch man i got
[ __ ] catfished
um we were still learning the
convenience store
yes i feel like we've just learned it we
got this white kid to work for us
so so the job that would change my life
the job that everything is predicated on
the [ __ ] fulcrum
upon which the lever of my life rests
comes from a moment where i'm like yeah
if i have to work at quick stop sure
yeah i guess
i don't get that opportunity i don't get
the opportunity to make clerks i don't
get the opportunity to
do anything i've done let alone [ __ ]
build rebuild [ __ ] smod castle or
watch as he does it and [ __ ]
um if if mr topper
doesn't make that journey if like and i
told
ria um rajiv's daughter mr topper's uh
granddaughter
like that at one point you know again
such a stoner i was like do you realize
that like if your grandfather like
doesn't come here
we're all [ __ ] like
he's literally our savior i was like
you're you don't get porn
like but i never make clerks and that's
the real crime
here you know um
in our house tonight ladies and
gentlemen is a man
um who gives us so much [ __ ] honor
the house doesn't deserve it standing
beside
the woman without whom he wouldn't have
done
anything uh my my both of my bosses
uh my my spiritual parents ladies and
gentlemen
the people that own the quick stop
building hence the building you're
sitting in
changed my life and changed all yours
give it up for tarlotian and starliter
that was that was literally worth it
that was worth the build and all that
[ __ ] we can all go home now good night
ladies and gentlemen
um all right man here's to the first of
many shows if i was clever i would have
gotten champagne or something like that
but i never think about that kind of
thing in advance all i think about is
like i get to talk
and i've done that and i get to talk
some more and stuff so
uh give it up uh for your castle keepers
man
ernie and rajiv